cruzar la selva del darién una travesía
que no todos pueden lograr un grupo de
emigrantes perdió la vida intentando
cruzar el tramo más difícil del viaje a
eeuu
mencionan muchos lugares ellos mencionan
bajando una loma la loma de la muerte
también han mencionado que en algunas
ocasiones migrantes han tenido accidente
la loma en una pendiente muy
tiene mucha pendiente y este han sufrido
algunos accidentes este año se han
recuperado al menos 44 cuerpos en darién
aquí hay personas que están caminando en
la selva y que tienen más de 60 años la
posibilidad de que tengo un ataque al
corazón porque tengo una infección son
alta o de que se caiga tengo una
fractura de cadera y no pueda seguir
caminando y posteriormente queda
abandonado en la selva la cifra es más
alta que en años anteriores cuando la
cantidad de cuerpos encontrados era de
15 personas en promedio un triste
reflejo de la mayor ola de migración
irregular a través del darién en poco
más de una década esta vez la ola es
liderada por haitianos provenientes de
brasil o chile que habían huido a estos
países luego de dejar haití tras el
devastador terremoto de 2010 las
autoridades panameñas estiman que más de
90.000 migrantes han cruzado por el
darién en lo que va de 2021 sin importar
los peligros advertencias y muertes
todos los días continúa el trayecto a
pesar de las recientes expulsiones y
deportaciones registradas desde la
ciudad texana de del río fronteriza con
méxico